Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Anyone who visits the nations of the West and then goes to Britain will see that everything in that country differs from elsewhere. The manners of administration, the style of life, the institutions of education and technology, even the form of cooking and housekeeping and the culture of entertaining. In sum, everything has a special form and nature which is quite different to other countries in the West. The British observe their national rights and social culture and they're much more insistent than others in retaining their laws and ethics, such that they're neither quick to anger nor revolutionary in temperament,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。任何去过西方国家然后再去英国的人都会发现，这个国家的一切都与其他地方不同。行政管理的方式、生活风格、教育和技术的制度、甚至烹饪和家政的形式以及待客文化。总之，一切都有其特殊的形态和本质，这与西方的其他国家截然不同。英国人坚守他们的国家权利和社会文化，并且在保留其法律和道德方面比其他人更加执着，以至于他们的脾气既不急躁也不是革命性的，
with the consequence that they do not quickly change their political and social organisation. The consequence of this spirit of conservatism is that the politics of Britain changes little. British cabinets last longer, and freedom of thought and opinion in this state is greater than in any other country, even though at the same time one can witness unprecedented levels of prejudice and superstition. So Tom Holland, that was the Persian language journal Iran Shah in 1923. And oh, how times have changed. Oh, how times have changed. And we are interested in the relations between Iran and, well, specifically England, aren't we? Because today England is playing Iran in the World Cup. What a showdown, Tom. You looking forward to it?
其结果是他们不会迅速改变其政治和社会组织。这种保守精神的结果是，英国的政治几乎没有什么变化。英国的内阁维持的时间更长，在这个国家，思想和言论自由比任何其他国家都更大，尽管与此同时人们也能目睹前所未有的偏见和迷信水平。那么，汤姆·霍兰德，那是1923年的波斯语期刊《伊朗沙阿》。噢，时代变了多少啊。噢，时代变了多少啊。我们对伊朗和——嗯，具体来说是英格兰——之间的关系很感兴趣，对吧？因为今天英格兰要在世界杯上对阵伊朗。真是一场对决啊，汤姆。你期待吗？
I am looking forward to it. Well, I remember the match that Iran played against America. When was that? It was 1998 and I remember that. They gave each other flowers, didn't they? Actually, the Iranians carried flowers. I'm not convinced that the Americans did. And I remember that so vividly because I was in France for that World Cup.
我很期待。嗯，我记得伊朗对阵美国的比赛。那是什么时候？那是1998年，我还记得。他们互相赠送了鲜花，不是吗？事实上，伊朗人带着花。我不确信美国人也带了。我对此记忆犹新，因为我当时在法国观看那届世界杯。
So I was watching it on a big screen in a square in, I think, Montpellier. And the square was packed with, you know, 3,000 people or something. And of all the people in the square from every country on earth, Colombians, Tunisians, Frenchmen, there were only two people in that square who wanted the united states to win and they were both americans one looked like bill bryson and the other looked like steven spielberg and you could see that not only were they gutted that the americans had lost they were absolutely confounded by the attitude of the crowd all their
所以我当时在，我想是在蒙pellier（蒙彼利埃）的一个广场的大屏幕上看的。广场上挤满了，你知道的，三千人左右。在广场上来自地球上每个国家的所有人中——哥伦比亚人、突尼斯人、法国人——只有两个人希望美国队赢，他们都是美国人。一个看起来像比尔·布赖森，另一个看起来像史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格。你能看出，他们不仅为美国队输球感到痛心疾首，而且对人群的态度感到彻底困惑——他们所有的
friends and allies who were madly cheering on iran iran did win didn't they they won one i think so two one i think it was actually in some ways it's it's amazing that iran are playing at all because when the revolution happened um do you know what the uh islamic revolutionary council said about football and why they were banning it they loved it and they thought it was brilliant was they said they said players have a tendency to behave aggressively when they play the sport true enough and in the aftermath of games supporters can also under influences which aren't good for them behave in an unbecoming manner well that would never happen in england no it certainly wouldn't and one of the reasons why um in the end iran carried on playing football is that
朋友和同盟都在疯狂地为伊朗欢呼。伊朗确实赢了，不是吗？他们赢了一场，我想是二比一，我想实际上是这样的。在某种程度上，伊朗能够参赛真是太神奇了，因为当革命发生时，呃，你知道伊斯兰革命委员会对足球以及他们为什么要禁赛是怎么说的吗？他们很喜欢它，并且认为它棒极了。他们说，他们说球员在踢这项运动时往往表现得具有攻击性——确实如此——而且在比赛结束后，支持者也可能在对他们不利的影响下，表现得不得体。嗯，这在英格兰是绝不会发生的。不，这当然不会。而呃，最后伊朗继续踢足球的原因之一是，
apparently the ayatollah was very keen on it and his son actually played quite a high standard. Anyway, but we have the perfect person to tell us whether that is true and more generally to talk about the long and troubled relationship between England and Iran, which is of course, very much friend of the show, Ali Ansari. Ali, thank you so much for joining us on this historic day great to be back so so for those people who don't know ali you're professor of history at st andrews but you're also you're you're you're an exile aren't you i mean that i am that's a very glamorous way to describe you but you are an exile you're an iranian exile and your family fled after the revolution in the end of the 70s i was actually being sent to uh i was being sent in in the classical sense i was being sent here to boarding school just before the revolution in the end of the 70s? I was actually being sent to, I was being sent in the
显然阿亚图拉对它非常热衷，他的儿子实际上踢得相当高水平。无论如何，但我们有最完美的人来告诉我们这是否属实，更广泛地谈论英格兰和伊朗之间漫长而多舛的关系，他当然是本节目的忠实朋友，阿里·安萨里。阿里，非常感谢你在这个历史性的日子加入我们。很高兴回来。那么，对于那些不知道的人，阿里，你是圣安德鲁斯的历史学教授，但你同时也是——你是一个流亡者，对吧？我的意思是——我是的，这是一个非常光鲜的词来形容你，但你确实是一个流亡者，你是一个伊朗流亡者，你的家庭在70年代末革命后逃离。我实际上被送往——我被送往，在经典意义上，我在70年代末革命前夕被送到这里上寄宿学校。实际上，所以这一切时机都很好。我们被送去，显然是因为英国，正如你最初的引述所概述的那样，是一个把人送去培养成公民（如果你愿意的话）的地方。你当时被训练成一个英国绅士，是吗？是的。效果显著，我必须说，阿里。我就是这么想的，是的。那么英国与伊朗关系的 history，它们是从什么时候开始的？伊朗人和英国人是什么时候开始意识到彼此存在的？我想英国人一直都知道波斯人，对吧？因为他们从古典资料和圣经中了解他们。
classical sense, I was being sent here to boarding school just before the revolution, actually, so it was all very well timed. And we were being sent, obviously, because Britain, as your first quote outlined there, was the place to send people to build citizens, if you will. You were being trained as an English gentleman, were you? Yes. To great effect, I must say, Ali. That's what I like to think, yeah. So the history of England's relations with Iran, when do they begin? When do Iranians and English people become aware of each other? I suppose the English are always aware of the Persians, aren't they? Because they know about them from classical sources and the Bible.
他们确实知道。我的意思是，有巨大的——我的意思是，这就是这段关系有趣的地方。这段关系比我认为某些神话所允许的要复杂得多、有趣得多、微妙得多。所以，我的意思是，显然在伊朗有一种关于“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”的看法，那就是……现在是小撒旦了，对吧？我们是木偶操纵者，对吧？是的。我的意思是，“小撒旦”有点具有欺骗性，因为——我的意思是，“小撒旦”基本上几乎控制了“大撒旦”。所以，它要复杂得多……
They do. I mean, there's enormous, I mean, this is the interesting thing about the relationship. The relationship is much more complex and interesting and nuanced than I think some of the sort of mythology will allow. So, I mean, obviously, there's a perception in Iran about perfidious albion, which is… The little Satan now, isn't it? We're the puppet masters, aren't we? Yeah. I mean, little Satan is slightly deceptive because, I mean, the little Satan basically almost controls the great Satan. So, it's much more…
所以，大撒旦是美国。是的。没错。最近伊朗拍了一部电影，有点像是在伊斯兰共和国拍的，一部精彩的历史纪录片。不得不说，纯属胡扯，但你知道的，播了大约40分钟，追溯了从尤利乌斯·恺世到当今时代“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”的历史。我很想看看那个。是的。不，不，我可以发给你。
So, the great Satan's America. Yeah. That's right. And there was a film recently made in Iran, sort of in the Islamic Republic, a wonderful history documentary. It has to be said, complete guff, but, you know, went on for about 40, tracing the history of Perfidious Albion from Julius Caesar through to the present day. I'd love to see that. Yeah. No, no, I can send it to you.
在第四频道（Channel 4）做一个节目。这是一个伟大的——你知道的，有很多关于海军的，还有关于阴谋诡计共济会的。听起来棒极了。而且，你知道的，关于英国尤其是英格兰的邪恶有一种连续性。我的意思是，当然，我们要记住的事情之一是，当伊朗人谈论英国时，他们倾向于谈论英格兰人。所以他们把英国说成是带有英国色彩的（Englishy），本质上是英格兰的。所以他们倾向于把这两者混为一谈。显然，这是他们一直在做的事情。但这确实是一个更加——是的，这是一个更加
Make a show on Channel 4. It's a great, you know, lots about the Navy and about, you know, the Skullduggery Freemasons. Sounds splendid. And, you know, there's a sort of a continuity about the wickedness of Britain and England in particular. I mean, of course, one of the things we have to remember is that when the Iranians talk about Britain, they tend to talk about the English. So they talk about Britain as Englishy, you know, essentially English. So they tend to conflate the two. And obviously, it's something they work on. But it's a much more, yeah, it's a much more
有趣的关系，我认为。当然，从西方人的角度，从英国人的角度，正如你所说，汤姆，你知道，人们出现时，他们从圣经、古典文本等地方了解“波斯”（加了引号的），他们对波斯所代表的事物有特定的印象。当他们在17、18世纪以更系统、更大规模去那里时，他们往往对他们所发现的有点失望。但是，你知道，这……你认为他们在期待什么？好吧，他们非常富有。你可能会高兴地知道他们非常非常——他们大量消化希罗多德。太棒了。所以他们半信半疑地期待，你会听到所有人都在说，好吧，你知道，我们以为他们——
interesting, I think, relationship. And of course, from the Western side, and from the English side, as you say, Tom, you know, people come along, they know Persia, in inverted commas, from the Bible, classical texts, all and so forth. And they have a particular impression of what Persia represents. When they go there in the 17th and 18th century in much more systematic and larger numbers, they tend to be a little bit disappointed by what they find. But, you know, it's... What do you think they're expecting? Well, they're very rich. You'll be pleased to know they're very, very, they digest Herodotus in large quantities. Excellent. And so they half expect, and you get all these people saying, well, you know, we thought they well you know we thought they you know
好吧，你知道，我们以为他们——你知道的，骑马、射箭、说真话，但坦白说，这些天他们没怎么做这些，嗯，这一切对他们来说有点令人困惑。他们谈论巴比伦，你知道，地名全错了诸如此类的事情，但是——但当然有一种文化包袱，从伊朗方面来看，这相当有趣——我的意思是，显然兴趣较少，有一些回忆录，在一些地理文本中提到过英国岛屿和其他地方。而且很有趣的是。所以爱德华一世派了一位大使去见其中一个伊朗统治者——伊儿汗，即伊朗的统治者，实际上是在十字军东征期间请求援助，你看，诸如此类的事情。但显然，这并没有实现。当然，这太雄心勃勃了。
rode horses shot the bow and told the truth but uh frankly they don't do many of those these days and um it's all a bit confusing for them and they talk about babylon and you know the place names all wrong and this sort of thing but um but certainly there's a sort of a cultural baggage there which is quite interesting from the iranian side i mean there's obviously less interest there are some uh reminiscences there's some sort of mentions of the island of Britain and others, you know, in some geographical texts. And interestingly enough enough. So Edward I sends an ambassador to one of the Iranian, the Ilkhans, the rulers of Iran, really asking for help during the crusade, you see, and this sort of thing. But obviously, that doesn't emerge. Surely, that's very ambitious.
是的，完全是。是的，波斯人可不会卷入十字军东征。当然蒙古人也不会。我的意思是，好吧，他们确实参与了。我的意思是，他们会与马穆鲁克等人作战，但不是代表基督教西方。所以这些是最初的接触，但它们非常非常稀少。直到16、17世纪，贸易联系和其他联系才真正开启。显然，东印度公司进入印度，并在17世纪显然发展了与伊朗的贸易联系。然后波斯在西方、在英国人的想象中变得更加突出。阿里，那是因为基本上印度的行政语言
Yeah, it's complete. Yeah. Yeah, the Persians weren't going to pile into the crusades. And certainly not the Mongols. I mean, well, they did. I mean, they would fight the Mamluks and others, but not on behalf of the Christian West. So those are the initial contacts, but they're very, very sparse. And it's really, you know, in the 16th and 17th century that you get trading links and others opening up. Obviously, East India Company moving into India and obviously developing their trading links with Iran in the 17th century. And then Persia becomes much more prominent in Western, in the English imagination. And Ali, that's because basically the language of administration
是波斯语。嗯，那就是——我的意思是，有趣的事情是，我（在关于这段关系的论点中）真正试图推动的观点之一是，英国或英格兰，当然最初是在印度占据主导地位。而在这个阶段，印度基本上是波斯语世界的一部分。我的意思是，莫卧儿帝国的行政语言是波斯语。当你去印度时，你学习波斯语是为了解事情是如何运作的。所以当英国人第一次旅行时——我应该说不列颠人，我的意思是，我很遗憾地说我们必须把它们混为一谈，因为最初的一些旅行者实际上是苏格兰人。当他们去伊朗时，他们是从印度来到伊朗的，他们确实来自一个特定的政治文化内部，这使得它变得非常非常有趣，因为（你知道）他们理解他们所去地方的文化习语，是的，所以他们带着所有的包袱，因为他们去过印度，他们知道事情是如何完成的，而且他们——波斯对他们很重要，大概——大概是因为印度，因为基本上通往印度的门户。实际上是为了防御。你看，所以基本上，东印度公司主要担心的是阿富汗和中亚对印度的威胁。所以他们把伊朗视为潜在的盟友。然后到了19世纪之交，他们真正理解到真正的威胁来自俄罗斯。
in India is Persian. Well, that's, I mean, the interesting thing is, so one of the ideas that I, you know, really try and push in my argument about the relationship is that Britain or England, certainly initially, becomes dominant in India. And India is fundamentally at this stage part of the Persianate world. I mean, the language of administration of Mughal India is Persian. When you go to India, you learn Persian in order to understand how things are going. So when Englishmen first travel, and Brits, I should say, I mean, I'm sorry to say we have to conflate a little bit because some of the first travelers are Scots, actually. When they go to Iran, they're coming to Iran from Indiaia and they come really from within
所以伊朗随后成为一个缓冲区。在那个时期，阿里，伊朗发生了什么？我的意思是，谁在统治它？它是一个什么样的国家，什么样的社会？所以18世纪结束时的伊朗，正处于一个政治动荡相当激烈的时期。我的意思是，在某些方面有点混乱。19世纪末出现了一个新的王朝。他们进入了更广阔的世界，并且
a particular political culture and that makes it much much more interesting because of you know they understand the cultural idioms of the of the place they're going to yeah so they've got all the baggage because they've been in india they know how things are done and they sort of persia is important to them presumably presumably because of India, because it's basically a gateway to India. It's defensive, really. You see, so basically, the East Indian Company is principally worried about the threat to India from Afghanistan and from Central Asia. So they see Iran as a potential ally. And then by the turn of the sort of 19th century, they understand actually the real threat is coming from Russia.
他们进入了一个与伊朗在17世纪末离开时有很大不同的世界。所以你有两个帝国力量，基本上是英格兰和印度，以及北方的俄罗斯帝国。他们面临着这个新的困境。你在伊朗看到的是，基本上是一个非常传统的现代前国家，面对着这两个正在现代化的国家，如果我可以这样表达的话。而这个挑战相当严峻。在某种程度上，他们非常着迷。“着迷”这个词可能太强了，但他们对英国人和英格兰人在印度做什么感到困惑。你知道，你们为什么在那里？英国人和——你知道，他们的所作所为是，他们基本上与伊朗培养关系，以便使其（你知道）使伊朗在面对俄罗斯时站在自己一边。随着这种关系的建立，它是一段非常有趣的关系。伊朗人自己对英国人的所作所为着迷。我的意思是，他们把这视为一个有趣的发展。当然，这也有帮助，在这个时期去伊朗的所有这些人都能说流利的波斯语，理解习语，理解礼节，知道如何驾驭它。
So Iran then becomes a buffer zone. In that period, Ali, what's going on in Iran? I mean, who's running it? What sort of country, what sort of society is it? So Iran comes out the 18th century, a period of quite intense political turmoil. I mean, it's a bit of a mess in some ways. You get a new dynasty emerges at the end of the 19th century. They emerge into the sort of wider world. And
而且它起作用了。你知道，这些人是政治官员、外交官和其他在这个时期特别擅长自己行业的人。伊朗人以这种方式买账了。其中许多人当然在19世纪初去了英国，以学习英国成功的秘密。秘密是什么？他们学到了什么？我的意思是，这当然是有趣的事情。他们弄清的事情以及英国人对他们所说的话——当你仔细看时，英国人在拿破仑战争之后来到这里，你知道，我们是一个顶尖国家。是的。是的，为什么我们是顶尖国家？因为我们应用了启蒙运动的教训——我的意思是，基本上这是一个彻底的启蒙叙事。他们来到这里，
they emerge into a world which has quite changed from the one that Iran left in the sense of the end of the 17th century. So you have two imperial powers, basically Britain and India, and the Russian Empire to the north. And they're faced with this new dilemma. And what you have in Iran is basically a very traditional pre-modern state facing these two modernizing states, if I can put it that way. And the challenge is quite severe. And they're very enamored in some ways. Enamored maybe is too strong a term, but they're sort of puzzled about what the British and the English are doing in India. You know, why are you there? The English and the, you know, what they do is they basically cultivate relations with Iran in order to make it, you know, to bring Iran on side vis-a-vis the Russians. And that relationship is quite an interesting relationship as it builds up. And the Iranians themselves are fascinated by what the English are doing. I mean, they sort of see this as an interesting development. It helps, of course, that all these people that go to Iran in this period are very fluent in Persian, understand the idioms, understand the etiquette, know how to navigate it.
这是一个彻底的辉格党叙事，对吧？他们基本上对伊朗人说——而且非常有趣的是他们说了这一点，这是在种族教条和所有这些事情之前——他们基本上说，你知道，150年前，我们是一个悲惨的，你知道，岛国种族，基本上杀死了我们的国王并做了各种令人讨厌的事情。这一切有点混乱。但我们应用了，你知道，三件事，你知道，纪律、法律、教育，你知道，看看我们现在在哪里。如果你也做这些事情，你就能实现所有这些事情。当然，对许多伊朗人来说，你知道，这是一个相当有吸引力的选择。所以阿里，基本上，这是大博弈的一部分，不是吗？
And it works. You know, these are individuals, political officers, diplomats, and others who are particularly good at their trade in this period. And the Iranians in that way sort of buy into it. And a number of them, of course, go to England in the early 19th century to learn the secrets of British success. What are the secrets? What do they learn? I mean, this is the interesting thing, of course. What they work out and what the British say to them, when you look at it, the British come at this period, post-Napoleonic wars, you know, we're a top nation. Yeah. yeah why are we top nation because we have applied the lessons of the enlightenment i mean basically it's a thoroughly enlightenment narrative they come in
这种俄罗斯和英国之间争夺影响力的巨大斗争。伊朗人，他们更倾向于站在英国一边还是俄罗斯一边？哪一个对他们更有吸引力？他们害怕俄罗斯。他们害怕俄罗斯。俄罗斯有在转瞬之间派兵的倾向。英国人没有那种能力。英格兰没有那种能力。他们是一个海军强国。他们不喜欢派军队。这非常昂贵。因此，在这一点上，英国在伊朗人的想象中并不是后来那种具有撒旦色彩的人物。完全不是。而这正是
and a thoroughly whiggish right and they basically say to the iranians they say and it's very interesting that they say this is pre you know racial dogma and all this sort of thing they basically say you know 150 years ago we say, you know, 150 years ago, we were a miserable, you know, island race, basically killed our king and did all sorts of nasty things. And it was all a bit of a mess. But we applied, you know, three things, you know, discipline, law, education, you know, and look where we are now. And if you do these things, too, you can achieve all these things. And of course, for many Iranians, you know, this is quite an attractive option. And so Ali, it's basically, it's part of the great game, isn't it?
问题的核心，当然，基本上伊朗和英国之间关系的问题在于，在某种意义上，对于这个时期的伊朗人（特别是进行改革的伊朗人）来说，英格兰代表了一种志向高远的权力。我的意思是，他们喜欢政治理想。让他们感到恼火的是——我的意思是，这是一个根本问题。伊朗人对俄罗斯没有任何期望。他们认为它在某些方面相当粗鲁，但是，你知道，专制政体等等。所以他们对俄罗斯没有任何期望。好的。他们认为它在某些方面相当粗鲁，但是你知道，专制政体等等。所以他们没有经验。
This great kind of struggle for influence between the Russians and the British. Do the Iranians, are they more inclined to side with Britain or with Russia? Which is more appealing to them? They fear Russia. They fear Russia. Russia has the propensity to send troops in at a moment's notice. The British don't have that capacity. The English don't have that capacity. They're a naval power. They're not keen on sending troops. It's very expensive. At this point, then, Britain is not the kind of satanic figure in the Iranian imagination that it later becomes. Not at all. And this is the core of
所以对于英国人来说，没有什么好背叛的。另一方面，你知道，他们有一种期望，即英国人会不辜负他们的理想，这相当辉格党式，你知道，然后基本上英国人没有做到。
the issue, of course, is that basically the problem in the relationship between Iran and England in that sense is that England represents for the Iranians, particularly reforming Iranians at this time, a sort of an aspirational power. I mean, they like the political ideals. What they get annoyed about, I mean, this is a fundamental issue. Iranians have no expectations of Russia whatsoever. They think it's basically rather brutish in some ways, but, you know, autocracies and all that. So they have no expectations of Russia whatsoever. Okay. They think it's basically rather brutish in some ways, but you know, autocracies and all that. So they have no experience.
所以他们会想，等一下，你知道，你们有所有这些美好的理想，为什么你们不支持我们的投标？你知道，就是这样。有那种对比。
So there's nothing to betray for the English. On the other hand, you know, they have this sort of expectation that the British will live up to their ideals, which is rather Whiggish, you know, and then basically the British don't.
你在20世纪后期的美国人身上也能看到这一点。所以，阿里，你给我们发了一段摘录，选自一本叫《波斯王子日记》的东西。是的。所以这些是访问过英国的人。是的。他们是什么时候访问的？所以他们在1835年访问。他们确实去了。所以在整个19世纪初，你有一系列访客来到这里，观察英国社会、英国社会的各个方面。他们对我们本能地不会认为是重点的东西留下了深刻印象。
So they go, well, hang on a minute, you know, you have all these wonderful ideals and, and why aren't you supporting us in our bids? You know, this is the thing. There's that sort of contrast.
但这是诸如自由、解放之类的事情。他们对报纸着迷。他们无法理解报纸的概念——这种理念是，你出版十万份报纸，然后把它扔进垃圾桶，第二天重新开始，你知道，我的意思是，对他们来说，他们有点像是在说，这太棒了。他们对——本质上是经济发展和工业着迷——顺便说一句，他们观察的事情之一，有趣的是，是海军。你知道，海军是让他们印象深刻的东西，其背后的工业我认为是让他们印象深刻的东西。他们从来没有被带去参观
And you see this with the Americans, too, later in the 20th century. So, Ali, you sent us an excerpt from a thing called The Journal of the Persian Princes. Yeah. So these are guys who visited England. Yeah. And when did they visit? So they visited in 1835. And they do. So throughout the early 19th century, you get a series of visitors who come in, look at various aspects of English society, British society. They're enormously impressed by things that we wouldn't instinctively think would be the thing.
你知道的阅兵式，那不是让他们印象深刻的东西。他们被带去参观的是——三个王子也这样做了——泰晤士河隧道，你知道。是的，他们去——他们正在河底下建一条隧道，你知道怎么做？因为这是——因为这是英国作为世界工厂的全盛时期，我想。没错。所以他们认识到这是英国权力的发动机，我猜。但他们也喜欢政治，不是吗？他们在这里有一个精彩的段落，向他们的波斯读者解释政治。所以他们说，有大量的维齐尔（大臣），所有的维齐尔都有副维齐尔。
But it's things like liberty, freedom. They're fascinated with newspapers. They can't understand the concept of newspapers this idea that you publish a hundred thousand papers and then bin it and then start again the next day you know i mean for them they sort of go you know this is amazing they're they're fascinated by you know essentially economic development and industry and one of the things that they do look at by the way interestingly is is the navy you know the navy is something that impresses them the industry behind it i think is what it impresses them they're never taken around to see
尽管这些维齐尔中的每一个人都是他自己部门的主管，但他们不经彼此商量是绝不喝水的。他们不经彼此商量什么都不做。然后他们继续解释。他们基本上说托利党就是辉格党。有时父亲是辉格党，儿子是托利党，两个兄弟，可能一个是托利党，另一个是辉格党。他们说托利党遵循的差异如下。这是托利党。
you know military parades that isn't what what impresses them and they're not they're what they're taken to see is and the three princes do this is the thames tunnel you know yes they go what they're building a tunnel under the river you know how because this is the hey that? Because this is the heyday of Britain as the workshop of the world, I suppose. That's right. And so they recognize that this is the motor of British power, I guess. But they also love the politics, don't they? They've got a brilliant section here about explaining politics to their Persian readers. So they say, there's loads of viziers and all the viziers have vice viziers.
他们说，300年前，我们是野蛮人，我们当时的王国比任何其他王国都要糟糕和低等。但通过头脑、智慧和学习，我们把我们的王国提升到了目前的荣誉高度。而且由于我们的帝国通过我们的管理变得更大，我们为什么要改革并放弃给我们带来这么多好处的政策呢？所以这就是托利主义。然后是辉格主义，他们说，我们知道顺应时代和环境的变化更为明智。此外，根据旧政策，只有少数人获利。既然那个政府是一个普及的政府，我们就必须观察什么对整个国家最好，所有人都应该获利，每个人都应该享有相同的特权。我的意思是，他们的看法并没有错得离谱，对吧，我想？我的意思是，有趣的是，看着那个，
Although every one of these viziers is a master of his own department, they do not drink water without the advice of each other. They do nothing without consulting each other. Then they go on to explain. They say basically the Tories are Whigs. Sometimes the father is a Whig and his son a Tory, and two brothers, maybe one a Tory and the other a Whig. They said the difference between the Tories follows. This is the Tories.
我自己读下来的感觉是，很明显，这三个王子特别是正在与（你知道的）他们的对话者交谈，在某种程度上也就是像帕麦斯顿这样的人。所以这是相当——你知道的，他们接受了一种非常热血的辉格主义，我必须说。他们和一大群辉格党人混在一起。是的，他们基本上对他们说，托利党全是这样的。
They say, 300 years ago, we were wild people, and our kingdom then was worse and lower than any other. But through mind, wisdom, and learning, we have brought our kingdom to its present height of honor. And as our empire grew larger by our management, why should we reform and give up our policy, which has done all this good? So that's Toryism. And then Whiggism, they say, we know that it is more prudent to go according to the changes of time and circumstances. Moreover, by the old policy, only a few were profited. And as that government is a general one, we must observe that which is best for the whole nation, and that all should be profited, and every person should enjoy the same privileges. I mean, they're not wildly wrong, are they, I suppose? I mean, the interesting thing is, looking at that,
我的意思是，这实际上是一个非常有趣的引言。而且，你知道，他们彻底消化了这一点。我的意思是，他们接受了这种叙事，并希望回到伊朗说，看，你知道，我们可以做到这一点。我们可以发展这个。当然，英国人，对他们来说，这是他们获得影响力的方式。所以回到汤姆关于大博弈的评论，俄罗斯人在伊朗臭名昭著，因为他们想达到目的时基本上使用粗暴的武力。相比之下，英国人被视为要微妙得多。他们正在做的是，通过说服，试图把
and my own sort of like reading through it, is that it's clear the three princes in particular are talking to, you know, their interlocutors, in a sense, so people like Palmerston. So it's quite, you know, they're taking a thoroughly red-blooded Whiggism, I have to say. They're hanging around with loads of Whigs. Yeah, and they're basically saying to them, the Tories are all this.
人们争取过来。你可以看到我们做了什么，效仿我们。你知道，这就是前进的道路。这就是这段关系本质的有趣之处，我认为这段关系的问题之一是它的亲密性。你知道，意识形态上的亲密性，实际上问题之一是，伊朗人发现英国模式极具吸引力。他们也知道，例如，英国由四个不同的国家组成。你知道，他们有点说是威尔士、苏格兰、爱尔兰、英格兰。他们喜欢这种理念，在他们自己的某种程度上——他们看待自己的某种帝国王国，如果我可以这样表达的话。他们说，啊，这也是我们可以管理现代“民族”国家发展的一种方式。看看英国人是怎么做到的。这非常聪明，这里有一点微妙，那里有一点权力下放，有一点——你知道的，诸如此类的事情。
I mean, it's quite an interesting quote, actually. And, you know, they ingest this thoroughly. I mean, they buy into this narrative and they want to go back to Iran and say, look, you know, we can do this. We can develop this. And, of course, the British, for them, for them, this is the way they gain influence. So going back to Tom's comment about the great game, the Russians are notorious in Iran for basically using brute force when they want to get their way. The British, on the other hand, are seen as much more subtle. What they're doing is they're, by persuasion, trying to bring
这不是一个——到了19世纪末、20世纪初，人们真正开始接受的东西。他们这样做——我的意思是，他们这样做的另一种方式是，顺便说一句，这些人中有许多人都成了共济会员。我的意思是，他们都加入了共济会分会。而且，你知道，他们中的许多人谈论过它，三个王子自己说，我们在英国加入了一个分会。而且，你知道，他们谈论的，我想是肯特公爵什么的。所以当然，目前在伊斯兰共和国，你知道，这一切都非常阴谋论。他们都说，是的，这是令人震惊的坏事。但当然，在19世纪，共济会是非常反传统的。它是——在某种程度上，反有组织的宗教。
people over. You can see what we've done, emulate us. You know, this is the way to go forward. And this is the interesting thing, really, about the nature of the relationship is that I think part of the problems in the relationship is the intimacy of it. You know, the ideological intimacy of it, that actually one of the problems is, is that the Iranians find the British model extremely attractive. They also know, for instance, that Britain is composed of four different countries. You know, they sort of say it's Wales, Scotland, Ireland, England. And they like this idea in their own sort of, they look at their own sort of imperial kingdom, if I can put it that way. And they say, ah, this is a way also in which we can manage a sort of a development of a modern, quote, national state. Look at how the British have done it. It's very clever, a little bit of subtlety here, a bit of devolution there, a bit of, you know, this sort of thing.
它是反迷信的。这完全关乎创造新的政治现实。当然，伊朗的许多人，甚至宗教人物，也成为了共济会员并加入了这一行列，成为了我所认为的这种国际知识分子兄弟会的一部分。所以他们融入了这一切。而这一切的高潮是1906年伊朗的立宪革命，它强烈地以英国的议会民主制为蓝本。它甚至被一些领导人描述为，你知道的，“大英国的精神之子”。现在，如果我这样对你——正如你所说，你的反应绝对就是这样，在今天的背景下，人们会说，天哪，你知道，
It's not a, it's something that by the end of the 19th, early 20th century, people are really, really buying into. And they do this, I mean, another way in which they do it is a lot of these people all become Freemasons, by the way. I mean, they all join the Masonic lodges. And, you know, a number of them talk about it, the three princes themselves say, we join a lodge in England. And, you know, they talk about, I think it's the Duke of Kent or something. So of course, currently in the Islamic Republic, you know, it's all very conspiratorial. And they all say, you know, yes, it's shocking bad. But of course, in the 19th century, Freemasonry was very iconoclastic. It was, you know, anti, in a sense, organized religion.
为什么会有人这么说？但它就在文本里。我的意思是，你知道，你看到它，你读到它。他们这么说是因为他们实际上在恳求——讽刺的是——英国的支持，而这种支持，我们该怎么说呢，在革命的直接后果中有点在消退。他们在失去兴趣。他们不想惹恼俄罗斯等等。所以伊朗革命者会说，等一下。这是你们的孩子，而你们却在抛弃我们。在我看来，这是一个关键时刻。所以本质上，通过19世纪的关系，相当多的伊朗人对英国充满了钦佩。特别是知识分子阶层。是的。因此，这也是巨大失望的温床。没错。
It was anti-superstition. It was all about creating new political realities. And of course, many, even religious figures in Iran became Freemasons and joined up to this and became part of what I would consider this sort of international intellectual brotherhood. So they feed into it. And the apogee of all this is the constitutional revolution in Iran in 1906, which is fiercely modelled on a British system of parliamentary democracy. And it's actually described by some of the leaders as, you know, the spiritual child of Great Britain. Now, if I was to say that to you, as you say, and your reaction is absolutely it, in the context of today, people go, you know, oh my God, you know,
而这才是关键。这个想法实际上是因为你有巨大的钦佩，当英国人没有兑现承诺时，你就会感到失望。所以有一个段落，我想我以前和你说过，汤姆，关于奴隶制。所以有一个波斯王子与东北伊朗（中亚的呼罗珊）的英国大臣交谈。他说，你们为废除奴隶制做了那么多，却什么也不做来帮助我们，你知道的，应付中亚的奴隶制。你们为什么不帮我们？
why would anyone say that? But it's in the text. I mean, you know, you see it, you read it. And they're saying that because they're pleading, actually, ironically, for British support, which is, how should we say, in the immediate aftermath of the revolution is sort of slightly sort of fading. They're losing interest. They don't want to annoy the Russians and all this sort of thing. So the Iranian revolutionaries are saying, well, hang on a minute. This is your baby and you're dumping on us. It's a critical moment in my view. So essentially the relationship through the 19th century, there's admiration for Britain on the part of quite a lot of Iranians. Particularly the intellectual class. Yeah. Therefore, also huge scope for disappointment. That's right.
我的意思是，显然，英国人不采取任何行动有明显的原因，你知道的。但有趣的是，英国官员说，你知道的，他说，老实说，王子说得有道理。你知道，我的意思是，你知道，我们实际上并没有——你知道，我们并没有真正帮助他们解决土库曼袭击者等人的袭击。但他说，你知道，我不明白。你们怎么能这么——你知道的，你们在国际上很有名。我想这是在1850年代，1860年。所以，你知道，这很有趣。我的意思是，我不想说——让我们不要得意忘形，说一切都很美好，因为当然，在1850年代有过一场非常短暂的英波战争。关于英波战争（这场战争与阿富汗有关）有趣的事情是，英国人在战争结束时对其实行了非常宽容的条约。
And that's the key. It's the idea being really that because you have huge admiration, you feel disappointed when the English don't deliver on it. So there was a passage, which I think I've talked to you before, Tom, about slavery. So there's a Persian prince who talks to the British minister in Northeastern Iran, Khorasanian in Central Asia. And he says, you who have done so much to abolish the slave trade, do nothing to help us, you know, cope with the slave trade in Central Asia. And why don't you help us?
我的意思是，他们没有——这不是一项惩罚性条约。当然，具有讽刺意味的是，或者说矛盾的是，1857年之后发生的事情是，它甚至更多地敞开了通往英国思想的大门，因为知识分子说，实际上，你知道，战争，你知道，让我们把它抛在脑后。但实际上，《巴黎条约》的结果与俄罗斯人会做的事情相比是如此宽容，以至于，你知道，在某些方面与英国人合作也许确实有一些优点。当然，英国人随后卷入了一系列经济特权，部分原因是某些人竞标，他们
I mean, obviously, there are obvious reasons why the British don't do anything, you know. But interesting enough, the British official says, you know, he says, you know, to be honest, the prince had a point. You know, I mean, you know, we're official says, you know, he says, you know, to be honest, the prince had a point. You know, I mean, you know, we're not actually, you know, we're not helping them really in some of this stuff with these raids from Turkmen raiders and whatever. But he says, you know, I don't understand. How can you be so, you know, you're well known internationally. This is in the 1850s, I think, 1860. So it's, you know, it's interesting. I mean, I don't want to say let's not get too carried away and say it's all rosy, because of course, there was a very brief Anglo-Persian war in the 1850s. The interesting thing about the Anglo-Persian war, which was about Afghanistan, was that the British actually at the end of the war had a very lenient treaty on it.
他们有点说，让我们引入经济投资，因为那将催化改革。但当然，这导致了我们的——我猜是英伊关系的下一个重大方面，那就是伊朗石油工业的建立。这显然也是一个关键因素。所以我们休息一下。然后当我们回来时，让我们看看20世纪，这也许是一个更加麻烦的时期。所以从这里开始走下坡路了，伙计们。我们将在休息后回来，继续这段下坡路之旅。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
I mean, they didn't, it was not a punitive treaty. And of course, ironically, or paradoxically, what happens after 1857 is that it opens the doors even more to British ideas, because people, intellectuals say that actually, you know, the war, you know, let's put it behind us. But actually, the Treaty of Paris that results in it is so lenient compared to what the Russians would have done that, you know, maybe there is some merit in working with the British in some ways. And of course, the British then get involved in a series of economic concessions, partly in a bid by some people, they And of course, the British then get involved in a series of economic concessions, partly in a bid by some people, they sort of say, let's get economic investment in because that will catalyze reform. But of course, it leads to our, I suppose, our next great sort of
我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八盒秀八卦的每周固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，嗯，为了纪念今天英格兰在世界杯上对阵伊朗，我们正在与阿里·安萨里讨论英格兰与伊朗的关系，阿里，你把我们
like aspect of Anglo-Iranian relations, which is the establishment of the oil industry in Iran. And that's obviously a critical factor as well. So let's take a break. And then when we come back, let's look at the 20th century, which is perhaps a more troubled period. So it's all downhill from here, guys. And we will see you after the break for that downhill journey. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
带到了20世纪，英国和伊朗之间的关系——英国一直在盛气凌人，有点欺凌，我猜，但在伊朗并没有被彻底痛恨。伊朗人中有欣赏英国某些方面的人，但在20世纪，事情开始走下坡路，是吗？嗯，我的意思是，你知道，有趣的事情是，19世纪有许多事件并没有进展得特别好。显然有——你知道的，你提到的那场战争，1891年的烟草抗议运动。但有趣的是，你知道，甚至在1906年，正如我所说，你知道，当你经历这场立宪革命时，他们仍然称其为“大英国的精神之子”。与此同时，但稍微在边缘的是，当时伊朗政府决定向一个澳大利亚裔英国企业家提供石油特许权，
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history and um in honor of uh england playing iran today in the world cup we are discussing anglo-iranian relations with ali ansari um and ali you have
一个名字叫诺克斯·达西（Knox Darcys）的绅士，他获得了在伊朗南部勘探和开发所有石油资源的特许权。坦白说，主要是大约四万英镑左右。哇，那可真是一笔划算的交易。我的意思是，这并非微不足道。我的意思是，人们所说的话很有趣。尽管事后看来我们认为这一切都是板上钉钉的，但他们花了七年时间才真正打出石油，
taken us up to the 20th century um things between Britain and Iran, I mean, Britain's been throwing its weight around, slightly bullying, I guess, but not absolutely detested in Iran. There are aspects of Britain that people in Iran admire, but with the 20th century, things start to go downhill, do they? Well, I mean, you know, the interesting thing is, is that there are a number of episodes in the 19th century, which don't go particularly well. There's obviously the, you know, the war, which you mentioned, there's a tobacco revolt in 1891. But interestingly enough, you know, even in 1906, as I said, you know, when you get this constitutional revolution, they still talk about it as the spiritual child of Great Britain. Concurrently with this, but slightly over the margins, is the decision by the then government of Iran to offer an oil concession to an Australian British entrepreneur,
而且为了试图发现它花费了巨额资金。不得不说，他们差点就要放弃了。但他们知道那里有石油，对吧？因为多年来一直有石油从地下冒出来之类的地方。是的。我的意思是，这就是悖论之一，他们知道那里有一些石油。问题在于，以商业上可接近的数量找到它。当然，人们忘记了，当然，这是非常不毛的地形。我的意思是，就正在进行的工作而言，这是一个内部通讯非常少的国家。没有公路、铁路或任何东西，所以，你知道，在某些方面这是一项真正艰巨的任务。尽管如此，到1908年，他们打出了石油。
a gentleman by the name of Knox Darcy, of all names, who gets a concession for the exploration and exploitation of all oil resources in southern Iran. Principally, some of around £40,000, it has to be said. Wow, that is a bargain. I mean, it's not insignificant. I mean, it's interesting what people say. Although retrospectively we think it was all a done deal, it took them seven years to actually strike oil
在这个阶段，为了提供一点背景，立宪革命正在迅速走向衰落。英国人在1907年与俄罗斯签署了一项公约，基本上解决了他们在波斯和亚洲其他地方的争端，被英国外交官认为是背叛，我必须说。但坐在伦敦的爱德华·格雷并不太担心这种事情。他更对欧洲感兴趣。但有趣的是，为了说明石油特许权是多么微不足道，1907年的《英俄条约》基本上将伊朗分裂为这些势力范围，基本上忽视了石油特许权。我的意思是，没有——它甚至不包括
and a huge amount of money was spent to try and discover it. And they almost came close to giving up, it has to be said. But they know the oil's there, right? Because there have been places where oil has been bubbling out of the ground and stuff like that for years. Yeah. I mean, this is one of the paradoxes is that they know there's some oil there. The trouble is, is to find it in commercially accessible quantities. And of course, what people forget, of course, is that it's very inhospitable terrain. I mean, in terms of the work being done, this is a country that has very little internal communications. There's no roads or railways or anything. So, you know, it was a real hardship task in some ways. Nonetheless, by 1908, they strike a will.
伊朗西南部。还没有人为此操心。他们没有——你知道，从英国人的心理学意义上说，石油还没有真正产生影响。但在1908年石油被发现之后，它显然变得重要起来，然后在第一次世界大战前夕，丘吉尔作为海军大臣，决定皇家海军将从燃煤转向燃油。从那一刻起，伊朗对英国来说成为了一项具有战略重要性的资产，如果我是指英伊（Anglo-Iranian）石油公司的话——英伊、英波、英伊石油公司。所以在19世纪，伊朗有点像缓冲国、大博弈等等。到了20世纪，它发生了彻底的转变，变成了
By this stage, just to put a little bit of context, the constitutional revolution is going south very quickly. The British have signed a convention with Russia to basically settle their disputes in Persia and other places in Asia in 1907, considered by British diplomats as a great betrayal, I have to say. But Edward Gray sitting in London doesn't worry too much about this sort of thing. He's much more interested in Europe. But interestingly, just to show how insignificant the oil concession was, the Anglo-Russian Convention of 1907, which basically splits Iran into these spheres of influence, basically ignores the oil concession. I mean, there's no, it doesn't even cover
在这个阶段，简单交代一下背景，立宪革命正在迅速走向失败。英国人与俄国人在1907年签署了一项公约，基本解决了他们在波斯和亚洲其他地方的争端。英国外交官认为这是一个巨大的背叛，我必须得说。但坐在伦敦的爱德华·格雷并不太担心这种事。他对欧洲更感兴趣。但有趣的是，为了说明石油特许权是多么微不足道，1907年的《英俄条约》基本上将伊朗划分为势力范围，却根本没有提及石油特许权。我的意思是，根本没有，它甚至没有涵盖
southwestern Iran. Nobody bothers about that yet. They're not, you know, oil hasn't really made an impact in the British sort of psychology in that sense. But it does become obviously after 1908, the discovery of oil, and then crucially in the run up to the First World War, Churchill, as first Lord of the Admiralty, decides that the Royal Navy will switch from coal to oil. And at that moment, Iran becomes a strategically important asset for the British, if I'm the Anglo-Iran, Anglo-Persian stroke, Anglo-Iranian oil company. So whereas in the 19th century, Iran was sort of the buffer state, great game, so on and so forth. By the 20th century, it switches completely and becomes,
伊朗西南部。当时还没有人在意这个。石油还没有真正在英国人的心理上产生那种影响。但毫无疑问，在1908年发现石油之后，特别是在第一次世界大战爆发前夕，作为海军大臣的丘吉尔决定英国皇家海军将从燃煤转向燃油。从那一刻起，对于英国人来说，如果算上英伊（盎格鲁-波斯/盎格鲁-伊朗）石油公司的话，伊朗就成了一个具有战略重要性的资产。因此，在19世纪，伊朗基本上只是一个缓冲国和大博弈的舞台，诸如此类。到了20世纪，情况彻底转变，变成了
you know, the strategic asset. And just to emphasize this, in curious, in that first decade of the 20th century, Britain plays a role as both being a midwife to the creation of the modern Iranian state through the constitutional revolution, but also the establishment of its first modern industry through the oil refinery in Abadan and the development of that. And it's difficult to underestimate actually the impact of this development of the oil industry. I mean, it's like investing in a modern industrial complex in a country that is just not modern. I mean, everything else about it, there was some comparison done about the level of industrial development in Iran in the beginning of the
你知道的，就是那项战略资产。为了强调这一点，我很感兴趣，在20世纪的头十年里，英国通过立宪革命，扮演了催生现代伊朗国的助产士角色，同时也通过在阿巴丹建立炼油厂及其发展，确立了伊朗第一个现代工业。实际上，很难低估石油工业发展的这种影响。我的意思是，这就像在一个根本不现代的国家投资一个现代工业综合体。关于这一点，有人对20世纪初
first half of the 20th century, actually. And the Anglo-Iranian oil company just, I mean, it puts everything else in the shade. I mean, there are no other factories, really, you know, to compete with it. That's the company that's the ancestor of BP. And is there a lot of resentment in Iran at that point, these foreigners, these sort of, you know, Christian foreigners
上半叶伊朗的工业发展水平进行过对比。而英伊石油公司把其他一切都比下去了。我的意思是，真的没有其他工厂能与它竞争。那家公司就是英国石油公司（BP）的前身。当时伊朗人对这些外国人——这些某种程度上你知道的基督徒外国人——
are coming in to exploit our natural resources, or are people just delighted that the work is there and that there's a hint of modernization and that, you know, the oil is flowing and money will come in? It coincides really with the rise of nationalist thought in Iran. And again, this is the sort of paradox. So British ideas, you know, to go back to, again, some of your earlier podcasts, you know, the sort of imperial idea and the british ideas encourage the development of nationalist thinking in many of these territories you know so iran develops a sort of a sense of nationhood by imbuing all this wiggism in that sense in the sort of idea of progress and you know let's develop our own and it's juxtaposed almost you
来到这里掠夺我们的自然资源，是感到非常怨恨，还是大家只是很高兴能有工作，有一点现代化的迹象，并且你知道，石油在流淌，金钱会进来？这确实与伊朗民族主义思想的兴起不谋而合。同样，这也是一种悖论。因此，英国的想法——再次回到你们早期的某些播客，那种帝国理念和英国的思想——在许多这样的地区鼓励了民族主义思想的发展。所以，伊朗通过将所有这些辉格主义思想融入其中，产生了一种国家意识，也就是那种进步的理念，你知道的，“让我们发展我们自己的”，而它几乎与……并存。
know it's all runs up against this sort of development of these, you know, these basically these huge concessionary economic sort of developments that have really nothing to do with the home country. The agreement made, there are two, I should say, there are two major British concessions in Iran. One is to run the National Bank effectively. The British Imperial Bank of Persia emerges, has all fiscal rights in Iran. The right to issue banknotes and so on and so forth. So that's one thing. We should put that to one side in that sense, but it's in the background and it is important as the story develops. But then also the Anglo-Iranian oil company, the deal that's made with Iran back in 1901, and it's revised many times forward, is really for a very, I mean,
你知道，这一切都与这些基本上是巨大的特许权性质的经济开发碰撞在一起，这些开发与本土国家实际上毫无关系。达成的协议——我应该说，在伊朗有两个主要的英国特许权。一个是有效运营国家银行。波斯英国帝国银行出现，拥有伊朗的所有财政权利。发行钞票的权利等等。所以这是一回事。在这个意义上，我们应该把这件事放一边，但它存在于背景中，随着故事的发展，它很重要。但同样，英伊石油公司，早在1901年与伊朗达成的交易，并且后来经过多次修改，实际上是非常……
it's a good deal for the British or the company in the sense that the amount of, quote, the royalties paid to Iran are royalties based on profits. That's a very unusual way to do it. Now, it might have made sense in 1901, where nobody took it seriously, in a sense. But by the 1930s, or the 1940s, when you get a fully fledged industry making huge profits, but also, you know, the Iranians are never allowed to look at the accounts, by the way. So, you know, what you have is this rather bizarre situation where the company is obviously very protective about what its profits are. And it does pay a significant sum to the Iranian government, but it doesn't basically share the data. It's quite clear that the British government
对于英国人或公司来说是一笔好交易，因为支付给伊朗的所谓特许权使用费是基于利润的特许权使用费。这是一种非常不寻常的做法。现在，在1901年这可能说得通，当时在某种程度上没有人把它当回事。但到了20世纪30年代或40年代，当你拥有一个获得巨额利润的成熟产业时，而且，顺便说一句，伊朗人从来不被允许查看账目。所以，你所拥有的是这样一种相当怪异的局面：公司对自己的利润显然非常保护。它确实向伊朗政府支付了相当大的一笔款项，但它基本上不分享数据。很明显，英国政府
is doing rather well out of it. The Royal Navy gets preferential rates on oil. And certainly, as you get into the Second World War, it's an absolutely pivotal asset in terms of supplying British forces with oil at preferential rates. And the British government also makes quite a good bit on corporation tax and stuff like that, which obviously the Iranians don't see anything out of. And so they become increasingly irritated by this imbalance. And just on Iran in World War I, in the Great War. So Iran was technically neutral, wasn't it? That's right. But the British and co kind of pile into the west of the country nevertheless,
从中获益颇丰。皇家海军获得了优惠的石油价格。而且毫无疑问，进入第二次世界大战后，就以优惠价格向英国军队供应石油而言，这是一个绝对核心的资产。英国政府还在公司税等方面赚取了相当可观的一笔钱，而伊朗人显然从这些中什么也看不到。因此，他们对这种不平衡越来越感到恼火。关于第一次世界大战中的伊朗，在伟大的战争中。所以伊朗在技术上是中立的，对吧？没错。但英国人和其他势力无论如何还是涌入了该国西部，
because they're fighting, because the British and the Russians are obviously fighting the Ottomans. So is that very destabilizing for Persia? I mean, do people resent that? They do, but probably, I think, mistakenly more, you know, actually the critical culprits in this are the Ottomans and the Russians. The British are very latecomers in this. I mean, they sort of protect their interests in the south, but the British really sort of enter the fray once the Russian Revolution takes place.
因为他们在作战，因为英国人和俄国人显然在与奥斯曼帝国作战。那么这对波斯来说非常不稳定吗？我的意思是，人们对此感到怨恨吗？他们确实感到怨恨，但可能，我认为，更错误的是，实际上这里的罪魁祸首是奥斯曼人和俄国人。英国人在这一点上是后来者。我的意思是，他们在南部保护自己的利益，但英国人真正介入冲突是在俄国革命爆发之后。
Russian forces are going AWOL. The British have to come in and pay these forces to keep them seamless. But in terms of the turmoil in the country, it's certainly true that it causes a huge amount of disruption, socioeconomic disruption, certainly. So it's, and there's a famine in the west of the country. People, there's a current mood in perfidious Albion sort of language to blame the British for the famine, but certainly it seems to be that the chief culprits for this were internal turmoil, the Ottomans, the Russians, and the British come in rather the country in 1941. So there's a period of occupation for about five years. And that's probably the first time that ordinary Iranians encounter the Tommy, if I can put it that way. You know, most Iranian encounters with Brits up until then are with diplomats and businessmen and others. By 1941-42, they're dealing with everyday Englishmen, essentially. And it's an interesting experience. And how does that go down? I mean, it goes down, it goes down. I mean, the British, I mean, they also encounter,
俄国军队正在开小差。英国人不得不进来给这些军队发饷以保持局势不崩溃。但就国内的动荡而言，这肯定导致了巨大的破坏，社会经济破坏是肯定的。所以它是……并且该国西部发生了饥荒。人们——在背信弃义的阿尔比恩（英国）之类的话语中有一种现行情绪，将饥荒归咎于英国，但当然，主要的罪魁祸首似乎是内部动荡、奥斯曼人和俄国人，而英国人在1941年进入了该国。因此，大约有五年的占领期。这可能是普通伊朗人第一次遇到汤米（英国士兵），如果我可以这样说的话。你知道的，在此之前，伊朗人与英国人的大部分接触都是与外交官、商人和其他人。到了1941至1942年，他们本质上是在和日常的英国人打交道。这是一次有趣的经历。情况如何呢？我的意思是，情况是……英国人，我的意思是，他们还遇到了……
obviously, Soviet soldiers, Russian soldiers and Americans come in after 1942. It's a pretty turbulent political and economic period. The Allies use Iran really as a sort of a bridge to, you know, that bridge to victory to supply the Soviet Union. There's a lot of political activity in terms of the fact that the Anglo-Americans and the Russians are basically competing for hearts and minds in the country. So because political life sort of opens up, things become quite febrile. And the political activity also turns to this notion of whether these concessions should be continuing in the country. The end of the Second World War, and then the end of the Raj in India,
显然，1942年后苏军、俄军和美国人也进来了。这是一个相当动荡的政治和经济时期。同盟国实际上将伊朗用作一座桥梁，你知道的，通往胜利的桥梁，以援助苏联。由于英美俄基本上在争夺该国的民心，因此有大量的政治活动。因此，随着政治生活的开放，局势变得相当狂热。政治活动也转向了这些特许权是否应该在这个国家继续存在的观念。第二次世界大战结束，然后是印度英属时期的结束，
that kind of basically changes the geopolitical circumstances quite profoundly, I would guess. But even more profound, I suppose, is the fact that America now is clearly a much more dominant power than Britain. And how long does it take Iranians to realise that it's going to be America that's the great Satan and Britain is being demoted to the rank of the little Satan. So it doesn't take too long, it has to be said. So, I mean, there's a sequence of events that are quite interesting. In 1945-46, the agreement of the Allies is that they will withdraw from Iran six months after the end of the war. And funnily enough, Stalin doesn't do that. Okay, the Russians
我想，这基本上会非常深刻地改变地缘政治环境。但我认为更深刻的是，美国现在显然是一个比英国远为占主导地位的大国。伊朗人花了多长时间才意识到，将成为“大撒旦”的是美国，而英国则被降级为“小撒旦”的行列？说实话，没花太长时间。所以，我的意思是，有一系列相当有趣的事件。在1945到1946年，同盟国的协议是他们在战争结束六个月后撤出伊朗。说也奇怪，斯大林没有这样做。好吧，俄国人
stay. So the Russians stay in northern Iran, Azerbaijan and these sort of areas and just hang in there. There is a certain amount of political maneuvering that goes on, where the Russians are offered an oil concession in the north, it is then sort of rather, it's sort of denied politically, there's a lot of machinations, which means the Russians eventually withdraw from northern Iran and don't get their oil concession. What this means is that many politicians in Iran then say, well, if we've managed to refuse a concession to the Russians, why can't we take another look at this concession in the south of the British and actually deal with that? And here we get to the great crisis in Anglo-Iran relations,
留了下来。所以俄国人留在了伊朗北部、阿塞拜疆和这些地区，赖着不走。发生了一定程度的政治操纵，俄国人在北部获得了一项石油特许权，随后这种特许权在政治上被某种程度上否认了，其中有许多阴谋诡计，这意味着俄国人最终从伊朗北部撤出，并且没有得到他们的石油特许权。这意味着伊朗的许多政治家随后会说，好吧，如果我们设法拒绝了给俄国人的特许权，为什么我们不能重新审视英国人在南部的这个特许权并实际处理它呢？在这里，我们迎来了英伊关系中的重大危机，
which has basically colored the entire relationship since then, which is essentially the oil nationalization crisis of 1951-53, where the are all nationalizing everything. So, you know, this seems to be part of the course. And interestingly, there's a wonderful account by Ernie Bevan who sort of says that, you know, even as early as 1946, he says, you know, it's going to be very difficult for us to lecture others as to what they do with their national assets while we're busy nationalizing everything here.
它基本上给自那以后（两国）的整个关系打上了烙印，也就是1951至1953年的石油国有化危机，当时（伊朗人）将一切都国有化了。所以，你知道，这似乎是意料之中的事。有趣的是，欧内斯特·贝文（Ernie Bevan）有一段精彩的记述，他大致说过，你知道的，早在1946年，他就说，你知道的，当我们忙着把这里的切都国有化的时候，我们要去教导别人如何处理他们的国家资产，将会非常困难。
Britain's foreign secretary. That's right. And he was very, I mean, I think Bevan was, you know, extremely astute and farsighted in a lot of his comments. The problem he has is he has a company that's incredibly archaic in its worldview. And both the British Imperial Bank of Persia, which basically loses its concessionary rights in 1948-49, but more particularly the Anglo-Iranian Oil Company, I have to say. I mean, if there's a villain of the piece, it really is, I'm sorry to say, the board of the Anglo-Iranian oil company that's incredibly reluctant to actually reconsider its relationship with Iran. And in fact, the Foreign Office is often saying, you know,
英国的外交大臣。没错。他的意思是，我认为贝文在很多评论中都极其精明和有远见。他面临的问题是，他有一家在世界观上极其陈旧的公司。无论是波斯英国帝国银行（在1948-49年基本上失去了特许权），还是更具代表性的英伊石油公司，我必须这么说。我的意思是，如果有一个故事里的反派，那真的就是——我很遗憾地说——英伊石油公司董事会，他们极其不愿意重新考虑与伊朗的关系。事实上，外交部经常说，你知道的，
you've got to make concessions. I mean, the world has changed. And of course, the Americans are bringing big pressure on. Now, here, it gets slightly murkier, because there is an assumption in Iran, of course, that the Anglo-American alliance is solid. They've just come out of the Second World War. It's all, you know, the special relationship. Actually, there's a huge amount of competition between the British and the Americans for dominance in the world. And the Anglo-Irish Oil Company allows Britain to purchase oil in pounds sterling. It's an enormously important asset. So as Tom says, when you relinquish India, you know, that's the balance of payments really goes south when India goes down, right? So India becomes independent. What Abadan allows Britain to do is to basically maintain a certain amount of, you know, great power status through the fact that it doesn't need to buy oil in dollars. The Americans, however, are very keen to ensure that they dominate the oil, you know, that oil will hence, you know, it gives them a stranglehold on that sort of natural,
你必须做出让步。我的意思是，世界已经变了。当然，美国人正在施加巨大的压力。现在，情况变得稍微有些扑朔迷离，因为伊朗有一种假设，即英美同盟是牢不可破的。他们刚刚经历第二次世界大战。这一切都是，你知道的，“特殊关系”。实际上，英国和美国之间为了争夺世界主导地位存在着巨大的竞争。英伊石油公司允许英国用英镑购买石油。这是一项极其重要的资产。因此，正如汤姆所说，当你放弃印度时，你知道的，当印度倒下时，收支平衡真的会一落千丈，对吧？所以印度独立了。阿巴丹允许英国做的事情，是通过不需要用美元购买石油，基本上保持了一定数量的（你知道的）大国地位。然而，美国人非常热衷于确保他们主导石油，你知道的，石油将因此（你知道的）让他们对那种天然的……
you know, that sort of primary resource. And so what you find in this period, which is not really detailed in many history books, is a trilateral negotiation between the British, the Americans, and the Iranians. And, you know, I would say actually, in some ways, the Americans play a not entirely helpful role in that either. It's, you know, it's an interesting dynamic. It's not simply the West versus Iran. But that coup, so 1953, isn't it? So Mossadegh, who you mentioned, who's the prime minister. So you have, it's the Pahlavi dynasty that's running Iran. That's right. The Shah, who's so famous to those of us of the generation who remember the Iranian revolution, Mohammad Reza Pahlavi, but his prime minister Mossadegh, he is toppled in 1953. And that's always cited now, isn't it? I mean, it's not just cited by Iranians. It's cited
你知道的，那种初级资源形成扼杀之势。因此，在这段历史时期，你所发现的是许多历史书中所没有详细记载的，是英国、美国和伊朗三方之间的谈判。并且，你知道的，我甚至可以说，在某些方面，美国人在其中也没有扮演完全有益的角色。这是一个有趣的动态。这不仅仅是西方对阵伊朗。但那场政变，是1953年，对吧？所以穆罕默德·摩萨台（Mossadegh），你提到过的那位首相。所以你拥有的是巴列维王朝在统治伊朗。没错。对我们这些经历过伊朗革命的那代人来说非常著名的国王——穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维，但他的首相摩萨台在1953年被推翻了。现在人们总是提到这一点，对吧？我的意思是，不仅仅是伊朗人在提。这是
by people who criticize American foreign policy, who talk about the Cold War as this sort of American meddling in other people's affairs. But am I right in thinking that ultimately that coup is as much British as it is American inspired? So basically, the coup is essentially devised by the British. The idea is, and again, what I say to people is you've got to understand, if you want to understand these things, of course, is that this is a post-war world. A lot of these people involved are all ex, you know, SOE, OSS individuals who think that actually doing this sort of thing is just part of the cause. I mean, it's, you know, they haven't really entered the post-war world yet. You know, this is what you do. Troublesome government, get rid of it. You know, I mean, let's find another way of doing it. And the plans are all then, you know, contingency planning is all done under the Attlee government. I mean, it's a Labour government sort of like thing. They all say, you know, this is just going nowhere.
那些批评美国外交政策的人所引用的，他们把冷战称为美国干涉他人事务的一种表现。但我的想法对吗，最终这场政变既是英国煽动的，也是美国煽动的？所以基本上，这场政变本质上是由英国策划的。这个想法是——再次强调，我对人们说的是，如果你想理解这些事情，当然，你必须明白这是一个战后世界。许多参与其中的人都是前特种作战执行处（SOE）、战略情报局（OSS）的成员，他们认为做这种事只是顺理成章的一部分。我的意思是，你知道的，他们还没有真正进入战后世界。你知道的，这就是你所做的。有麻烦的政府，除掉它。你知道的，我的意思是，让我们找到另一种方法来做这件事。然后所有的计划都是——应急规划都是在艾德礼政府的领导下完成的。我的意思是，这是一个工党政府做出的那种事情。他们都说，你知道的，这根本行不通，
We need to find people we can negotiate with. I think the critical factor is, and if you look at it in a two-way thing, is the only way it would have actually been done is because the Eisenhower government gave the go-ahead. I mean, the thing is, by the time the coup was actually launched, Britain had been diplomatically, you know, diplomatic relations with Britain had ended, the British embassy had been closed. The operation had to be run effectively out of the American embassy. Why had the British embassy been closed? Because basically, the Iranians were worried about a coup. I mean,
我们需要找到可以谈判的人。我认为关键的因素是——如果你从双边角度来看的话——它之所以能真正付诸实施，是因为艾森豪威尔政府开绿灯了。我的意思是，事情是这样的，当政变真正发起时，英国已经在外交上……与英国的外交关系已经断绝，英国大使馆已经关闭。这项行动实际上必须在美国大使馆内部运作。为什么英国大使馆会关闭？因为基本上，伊朗人担心政变。我的意思是，
they were basically saying, oh, the British are interfering and, you know, let's get rid of them and so on and so forth. They're worried about the British and a coup. But is that because the British have peculiarly formidable influence with the army, with elites? I mean, who are the people that the British is sort of, that sort of George Smiley is talking to? Well, basically, it's a whole range of it. There's a general consensus among the Iranian political elite. So if you go back to 1906,
他们基本上是在说，哦，英国人在干涉，你知道的，让我们摆脱他们之类的话。他们担心英国人和政变。但那是因为英国人在军队、在精英阶层中具有特别强大的影响力吗？我的意思是，英国人正在与之对话的人是谁——那种乔治·史密斯（间谍小说人物）式的人物？嗯，基本上，这是全方位的。伊朗政治精英之间存在着广泛的共识。所以如果你回到1906年，
you go back to the 19th century, it is that sort of rather schizophrenic attitude to the British, that they are both extremely good at politics, but also they are extremely good at politics but also they are extremely good at politics if i can put it that way so one is that we admire their politics but boy they're quite cunning you know and and in a sense what they're saying is you know we you know that they're all i mean the the the wonder of wonderful nature of this relationship is that
如果你回到19世纪，对英国人那种相当精神分裂的态度依然存在：他们既极其精于政治，但同时他们也极其精于政治，如果我可以这样说的话——所以一方面是我们钦佩他们的政治，但天哪，他们相当狡猾，你知道的。并且在某种程度上，他们所说的是，你知道的，我们……这种关系奇妙的本质在于，
basically the iranians look at the british as people who can do politics better than they can do it. So let's go forward to 1979 and the revolution. There are people in Iran, monarchists, who say that the whole Iranian revolution was kind of spun by the British Secret Service. Is that how seriously is that taken? I mean, I have two jokes. I was like, one is that the common one is they say that, you know, if you lift up Ayatollah Khomeini's beard, it says made in England. But the one that I always quite liked was, which is a slightly more subtle one, but great finding, is that because Ayatollah Khomeini couldn't say Margaret Thatcher very easily, he would always say, my great teacher, you know, and that was, he couldn't say, and people would joke, you know, my great teacher, you know, and, you know, there's this view.
基本上伊朗人把英国人视为比他们自己更擅长政治的人。所以让我们快进到1979年的革命。伊朗有一些人，保皇派，他们说整个伊朗革命是由英国秘密情报局（MI6）操纵的。这有多大程度上被当真？我的意思是，我有两个笑话。我总是喜欢……一个普遍的说法是他们说，你知道的，如果你掀开霍梅尼 ayatollah 的胡子，上面写着“英国制造”。但我一直挺喜欢的一个笑话，是一个稍微微妙一点但发现得很妙的笑话，是因为霍梅尼 ayatollah 不能很轻松地发音“玛格丽特·撒切尔”，他总是说“我的伟大老师（my great teacher）”，你知道的，那就是……他发不好音，人们就会开玩笑说，你知道的，“我的伟大老师”，你知道的，而且，有这样一种观点。
I mean, whichever political faction you are in Iran, you will tend to see Britain as the core of the issue. And what I try and tease out is it's not all it's a sort of a how could we put it? It's a it's a reluctant sort of admiration. If I can put it that way, they're quite impressed by the ability, you know. But so, Ali, in the in the revolution, obviously, it's the American diplomats who get taken hostage and the American embassy that gets closed down. The British embassy, there are no attacks on the British embassy, are there? There are. There are attacks on the British embassy, I think, early in the revolution. But they basically solved it. In fact, there were attacks on the American embassy too in the early stages of the revolution, but actually the protesters were moved out, which is why in the 4th of November 79, when they actually seized the embassy, a lot of American diplom might be this nest of spies and so on and so forth. And therefore we have to occupy it. At that time, the Shah had just gone for medical treatment to America.
我的意思是，无论你在伊朗属于哪个政治派别，你往往都会把英国视为问题的核心。而我试图梳理出来的是，这并不完全是……我们该怎么说呢？这是一种勉为其难的钦佩。如果我可以这样说的话，他们对这种能力相当印象深刻，你知道的。但是，阿里，在革命中，很显然，被扣为人质的是美国外交官，被关闭的是美国大使馆。英国大使馆，没有针对英国大使馆的袭击，对吧？有的。有针对英国大使馆的袭击，我想是在革命初期。但他们基本上解决了。事实上，在革命初期也有针对美国大使馆的袭击，但实际上抗议者被驱离了，这就是为什么在79年11月4日，当他们真正占领大使馆时，许多美国外交官……可能是这个间谍窝点等等。因此我们必须占领它。当时，沙王刚刚去美国接受医疗治疗。
So that's, you know, arguably what the spark for that was. I mean, interestingly, there's been a huge amount of reflection in Iran about whether the seizure of the American embassy was a good thing. And only diehards now in the revolution think it was a positive thing to do most people actually even those who actually took the embassy say that you know frankly it got a bit carried away and it's it's caused a lot of problems that you know just on the on the shah for a second so the shah had visited the uk hadn't he made a state visit yeah the queen the late queen elizabeth had been to iran um how how i know the sh Shah was educated in Switzerland, wasn't he? So he's not a British boarding school product. No, no, no. Perhaps unusually for a sort of 20th century monarch.
所以，你知道的，可以说这就是导火索。我的意思是，有趣的是，伊朗国内对于占领美国大使馆是否是一件好事进行了大量的反思。现在革命中的顽固分子认为这是一件积极的事情，而大多数人——甚至那些真正占领了大使馆的人——都说，坦率地说，当时有点冲动了，而且这造成了很多问题……顺便说一句，关于沙王，沙王曾访问过英国，进行过国事访问，对吧？是的，已故女王伊丽莎白曾去过伊朗……我知道沙王是在瑞士受教育的，对吧？所以他不是英国寄宿学校的产品。不，不，不。对于20世纪的君主来说，这或许很不寻常。
How much is he seen as a sort of, because of his royal connections and stuff, as a tool of the British? He would obviously not recognise himself as that. And he was very, very critical of that. And there are some wonderful interviews that you can see on YouTube now, you know, with Peter Snow, where he sort of lambasts the British. You know, he says, you know, you guys think you can manipulate us as you did 100 years ago.
他有多大程度上被视为……因为他的王室关系之类的事，被视为英国的工具？他显然不会认为自己是那样的。而且他对此非常、非常批评。现在你可以在YouTube上看到一些精彩的访谈，你知道的，皮特·斯诺（Peter Snow）采访他时，他严厉抨击了英国。你知道的，他说，你知道的，你们这些家伙以为你们可以像100年前那样操纵我们。
You know, it's not possible to sign and so forth. He was very fluent in English, by the way, fluent in French and English. And he conversed very easily in those. But yes, you know, his view was, his own view, that he was a strong nationalist figure in his own mind. But of course, in the popular revolutionary consciousness, people would say that, oh, no, he's a the minute David Owen got up in the House of Parliament and said, we stand full square behind the Shah, she said, that's it. He was doomed. Yeah. Said, pack your bags. It's time to leave.
你知道的，这不可能签（协议）之类的话。顺便说一句，他英语非常流利，法语和英语都很流利。他用这些语言交谈非常自如。但是是的，你知道的，他的观点是，他自己的观点是，在他自己心里，他是一个强硬的民族主义人物。当然，在民众的革命意识中，人们会说，哦，不，他是一个……就在戴维·欧文（David Owen）在议会发表讲话并说“我们全力支持沙王”的那一分钟，她（沙王后）说，就是这样。他完蛋了。Yeah.（她说）收拾行李。是时候离开了。
David Owen, kiss of death. But Ali, I mean, presumably, well, I mean, obviously, the effect of the occupation of the American embassy, all that crisis, everything, is that through the 80s, the great rivalry is between Iran and America. And Britain presumably is in the shadows. But then in, what is it, Valentine's Day 1989, the Ayatollah issues a fatwa against Salman Rushdie for the publication of the Satanic Verses. And that presumably puts Britain right back in the firing line. It does. I mean, it's always interesting why he issued that fatwa, whether people discuss whether it was a fatwa or not. I mean, most people assume it is now. They take it as read. Yes, it does. And it goes to the heart of this notion, by the way, that as much as America is the great Satan,
戴维·欧文，死亡之吻。但是阿里，我的意思是，大概，好吧，我的意思是，显然，占领美国大使馆的影响、所有的危机、所有的一切，就是贯穿整个80年代，巨大的竞争是在伊朗和美国之间。而英国大概处于阴影之中。但随后在——是什么时候？1989年的情人节，阿亚图拉因出版《撒旦诗篇》而对萨尔曼·鲁西迪（Salman Rushdie）发布了追杀令（Fatwa）。这大概把英国重新推回了风口浪尖。确实如此。我的意思是，他为什么要发布那个追杀令，人们是否讨论这是否是追杀令，这总是很有趣。我的意思是，大多数人现在认为它是。他们认为这是理所当然的。是的，确实如此。并且它直击这样一种观念的核心，顺便说一句，尽管美国是大撒旦，
I mean, for many Iranians of a certain generation, a certain ilk, they will look at Britain still as the source of, you know, the original sin, the source of evil, so on and so forth. They still talk of Britain at the moment, even in hardline circles in Iran, as the evil state. I mean, it's really quite, you know, the great Satan is almost, you know, he's bad. But the evil state of Britain is something really quite intense. They believe we control the Americans. Yeah. Britain is something really quite intense. They believe we control the Americans. Britain is America's brain. Well, I mean, Tom, to be fair, that's what you and I think.
我的意思是，对于某一特定世代、特定派别的许多伊朗人来说，他们仍然会把英国视为原罪之源、邪恶之源等等。他们目前仍然将英国称为邪恶国家，甚至在伊朗的强硬派圈子里也是如此。我的意思是，这真的相当……你知道的，大撒旦几乎是，你知道的，他是坏的。但英国这个邪恶国家则是某种非常强烈的东西。他们相信我们控制着美国人。是的，英国是某种非常强烈的东西。他们相信我们控制着美国人。英国是美国的大脑。好吧，我的意思是，汤姆，公平地说，这就是你和我所想的。
I say this to American colleagues. I say, I'm sorry to disappoint you, but this is the way they view it. And interestingly enough, I mean, there's obviously younger generations have a different view. And of course, it's never stopped. Even many of these people who think this, you know, it's never stopped them coming to Britain for education or medical treatment or so that, you know, they, again, that sort of rather sort of paradoxical view of Britain is there. And they always say, well, our hatred is for the British state. It's not for the British people. Yeah, you know, that sort of thing. I mean, that's what they say. It's all a bit of a, you know, it's a bit of a convenience, isn't it, really? The fact that Iran has been drawn for this group
我对美国同事也是这么说的。我说，很抱歉让你们失望了，但这就是他们的看法。有趣的是，我的意思是，年轻一代显然有不同的看法。而且当然，这从未停止过。甚至许多有这种想法的人，你知道的，这也从未阻止他们来英国接受教育或医疗治疗，所以，你知道的，他们，再次强调，对英国那种相当矛盾的看法依然存在。他们总是说，好吧，我们的仇恨针对的是英国国家。不是针对英国人民。是的，你知道的，类似的话。我的意思是，这就是他们所说的。这一切都有点……你知道的，这其实有点权宜之计，不是吗？事实上，伊朗已经被拉入了针对……这个集团
against both England and America and Wales. And Wales. So it's extraordinary. So three Satans, surely, I mean. Well, the Welsh probably get away with it. Does Wales count as a Satan? No, the Welsh would get away with it. In the same way as the Scots often get away with it,
同时对抗英国、美国和威尔士。还有威尔士。所以这太不可思议了。所以有三个撒旦，当然，我的意思是。好吧，威尔士人可能逃过一劫。威尔士算是一个撒旦吗？不，威尔士人会逃过一劫。就像苏格兰人经常逃过一劫一样，
even though a lot of the people operating in Iran in the 19th and 20th century, certainly the chairman of the Anglo-Iranian oil company was Scottish. What's the feeling in Iran about this match? Would it be seen as having any kind of symbolic resonance? And what's more broadly the state of relations with England at the moment? Well, I mean, as you know, there's been a lot happening in Iran recently. So, you know, the mood, I think, is quite different. I think in official, you know, political circles, there'll be lot of sort of uh geeing up some of the nationalist sentiment and you know let's give
尽管许多在19世纪和20世纪在伊朗活动的人——当然，英伊石油公司的董事长就是苏格兰人。伊朗对这场比赛有什么感觉？这会被视为具有任何形式的象征共鸣吗？目前与英国的关系大致处于什么状态？嗯，我的意思是，如你所知，最近伊朗发生了许多事情。所以，你知道的，情绪，我认为非常不同。我认为在官方的，你知道的，政治圈子里，会有很多……嗯，煽动一些民族主义情绪，你知道的，“让我们好好教训一下”
you know the little satan a good kicking and so on and so forth i think for the vast majority of people actually it's it's not going to be ideological at all i think they'll quite like the fact that they're playing england i mean you know there's a lot of to be honest interest and fascination with you know the premier league english football so on and so on i mean they love it so i think in some ways they'll find it quite um quite interesting and and and you know there'll be less vitriol i mean just to give you an example of how the mood has changed a few years ago there's an election in iran and for some reason you know the hardliner said you know you we must vote for the people that you know britain has uh uh has said we vote, you know, because basically there's some British, I think the BBC Persian service had said something like, you know, vote for these people.
你知道的，“小撒旦”，诸如此类的话。我认为对于绝大多数人来说，实际上，这根本不是意识形态的，我认为他们会很乐意看到他们对阵英格兰——我的意思是，老实说，你知道的，（人们）对英超联赛、英国足球等等有着极大的兴趣和迷恋；我的意思是，他们太喜欢了。所以我觉得在某些方面，他们会觉得这相当……相当有趣，而且，你知道的，会有更少的恶毒攻击——举个例子，为了让你们了解情绪是如何改变的，几年前，伊朗举行了一场选举，由于某种原因，你知道的，强硬派说，你知道的，“我们必须投票给英国人……呃……说我们应该投票的人”，你知道的，因为基本上有一些英国人，我想英国广播公司（BBC）波斯语服务部曾说过类似的话，你知道的，“投票给这些人”。
And they said, these are British stooges, don't vote for them. And in actual fact, when the vote came in, they all voted for exactly those people. I mean, basically, they ignored their own government and said, actually, we think these people are decent. So, again, I think there's a much, much more nuanced appreciation of Britain among the general public, certainly now, where there's much less adherence to what the official narrative is coming out of the government. And the Iranian footballers themselves have quite prominently, some of them have quite prominently supported the campaign against the headscarf. Absolutely. I mean, in previous occasions occasions these sort of quote celebrities uh sporting celebrities haven't really said anything they've kept uh studiously neutral now they're coming out there's a couple of leading for i mean they're managers now they're player managers and managers
他们说：“这些是英国的傀儡，不要投票给他们。”但事实上，当投票结果出来时，他们全都投给了正是那些人。我的意思是，基本上，他们无视了自己的政府，并说：“事实上，我们认为这些人很正派。”所以，再次强调，我认为广大公众对英国有了一种更加、更加细致入微的理解，当然现在也是如此，他们对政府发出的官方叙事的盲从要少得多。伊朗足球运动员本身也相当引人注目，其中一些人非常引人注目地支持了反对头巾的运动。绝对的。我的意思是，在过去的场合，这些所谓的名人……体育名人并没有真正说什么，他们一直保持着……刻意保持中立。现在他们站出来了，有几个主要的球星——我的意思是，他们现在是教练了，他们是球员兼教练和教练
um but you know heroes of the previous world cup and stuff like that i mean they've basically come out uh very much in support of the protesters and the government's actually find it quite difficult to know what to do about them um because they are immensely popular figures in Iran itself. And it's difficult to underestimate how popular football is, by the way. I mean, that's another example of the influence of Britain, isn't it? I mean, the popularity of football in Iran is enormous. It is, in effect, the national sport. I mean, most people talk about wrestling as the national sport. Just on that question about enduring British influence, something that always fascinates me is whether people learn British or American English.
——但是，你知道的，前几届世界杯的英雄之类的，我的意思是，他们基本上已经站出来……非常坚定地支持抗议者，而政府实际上发现很难知道该如何处理他们，因为他们在伊朗本土是极其受欢迎的人物。而且很难低估足球有多受欢迎，顺便说一句。我的意思是，那是英国影响力的另一个例子，不是吗？我的意思是，足球在伊朗的受欢迎程度是巨大的。它实际上是国民运动。我的意思是，大多数人把摔跤称为国民运动。正是在关于持久的英国影响力这个问题上，让我一直着迷的是，人们学的是英式英语还是美式英语。
So in Iran, would they still have that sort of 19th century sense of Britain as prestigious and whatnot, and would they adopt British accents when they speak English, or would they do what a lot of people now do and learn American English? I think it's, I mean, from my own experience, and limited as it is at the moment, I mean, I think it's, you know, their English is learned from films, songs, so on and so forth. I mean, it's all learned secondhand. And by and large, it would be, I don't know if you'd call it American
所以在伊朗，他们是否仍然保留那种19世纪对英国的声望等方面的感觉，他们在说英语时会采用英式口音，还是会像现在很多人那样学习美式英语？我认为，我的意思是——根据我自己的经验，尽管目前还很有限——我的意思是，我认为，你知道的，他们的英语是通过电影、歌曲等等学到的。我的意思是，这都是通过二手学来的。总的来说，这会是——我不知道你是否称之为美式
or British English, it's almost like an international English, if I could put it that way. But it's certainly, you know, I think the important point here is that English is the sort of second language in Iran. I mean, that's the interesting thing. I mean, people will learn English. They see English as the language that they need to learn to get ahead. And they're pretty good at it, I have to say. I mean, it's very interesting how cosmopolitan, you know, the Iranians have been. And if you go back even, you know, the past 200 years, there's a wonderful anecdote to the first Persian ambassador who came to Britain in 1809.
还是英式英语，如果我可以这样说的话，这几乎就像是一种国际英语。但当然，你知道的，我认为这里的重点是英语是伊朗的第二语言。我的意思是，有趣的是这一点。我的意思是，人们会学英语。他们把英语视为他们为了取得成功而需要学习的语言。而且我必须说他们学得相当好。我的意思是，伊朗人曾经是多么具有世界主义眼光，这非常有趣。如果你回溯甚至，你知道的，过去200年，有一个精彩的轶事：第一位在1809年来到英国的波斯大使，
And he starts to learn English, you know, as soon as he arrives. And apparently the Ottoman ambassador comes in and says, what on earth are you doing? And he says, well, I'm learning English. He says, what for? He said, well, I'm ambassador to Britain, you know. And he says, I've been here two years and I can't speak a word. And the Persian ambassador says, that's very odd. I mean, you know, I mean, so it's very interesting how they've sort of they're able to absorb.
他一到达就开始学习英语，你知道的。显然奥斯曼帝国大使进来后说：“你到底在干什么？”他说：“嗯，我在学英语。”那个人说：“为了什么？”他说：“嗯，我是驻英国大使，你知道的。”那个人说：“我在这里呆了两年，一个字都不会说。”波斯大使说：“那太奇怪了。我的意思是，你知道的，我的意思是——所以他们如何能够吸收（新事物），这非常有趣。
I mean, there's a certain, you know, going back to Herodotus and the ability of the Persians to sort of adopt and adapt and so on and so forth. There's a certain truth to that. They're very engaged. And I'm always very impressed today with Iranians as isolated as they are in many ways from the outside world and communications, not as much as people reckon. But still, even, you know,
我的意思是，有某种——回到希罗多德以及波斯人采用、适应等等的能力。这有一定的道理。他们非常投入。今天，尽管伊朗人在许多方面与外部世界和通讯隔绝——没有人们想象的那么隔绝，但依然如此——伊朗人的英语流利程度仍然给我留下了深刻的印象，考虑到他们实际上并没有真正的获取途径。所以阿里，在我们离开之前还有最后一件事。关于老狐狸的事，我读到过。所以有一位诗人，对吧，叫佩沙瓦里（Peshawari）。他的父亲在那场你提到的1850年代的战争中被杀。他写了这样一首诗，翻译过来是：
their fluency in English is impressive given they don't really get access. So Ali, one last thing before we go. This thing about the old fox I read about. So there's a poet, isn't it, called Peshawari. And his father was killed in that war that you mentioned in the 1850s. And he wrote this poem, the translation is,
在你潜入之后，许多古老的宅邸拔地而起。你通过你的狐狸伎俩夺取土地。你像一只老狐狸一样逃脱了数百个陷阱。这就是我们。这就是英国人。是的。这是一个伊朗人至今仍在使用的表达吗？是的，是的。我的意思是，在2016年，他们有一张巨大的海报，画着一只狐狸，穿着一件英国国旗（Union Jack）背心，这可能是一种世界杯的标志。它可能是那样的。这应该成为我们的吉祥物。是的。上面基本上写着，你知道的，邪恶的英国国家一直是伊朗永恒的敌人。当然，你知道的，从历史上看，这不是真的。但事实就是这样。
many an ancient house was raised after you crept in. You seize lands through your fox games. You have escaped hundreds of traps like an old fox. And that's us. That's the British. Yeah. And is that an expression that iranians still use to this yes yes i mean they had a huge poster in 2016 of a fox and a eugen jack waistcoat that could be a kind of world cup icon it could be that should be our mascots yes and it basically says you know the evil state of britain has always been an eternal enemy of iran of course you know historically that's not true. But there you are.
这就是他们会抛出的东西。而且再次强调，这里的讽刺之处在于，如果你看看地区历史，他们总是把波斯人看作是极其狡猾的。波斯人是那些使用煽动手段来达到自己目的的人。讽刺的是，伊朗人现在正在做的是将这一点转移到英国人身上，因为实际上英国人做得更好。但我们都很狡猾。我的意思是，我们都可以很狡猾。
That's what they'll put out. And again, the irony of it is that if you look at regional histories, they always look at the Persians as extremely cunning. The Persians are the ones that use sedition to get what they want. And ironically, what the Iranians are now doing is transferring that onto the British because actually the British have done it better. But we're both cunning. I mean, we can both be cunning.
是的，我们都是狐狸。你知道的，这也是……但我认为，你知道的，如果我可以这样说的话，其正当理由是这样一个根本点：虽然政治——英国政治对伊朗人来说总是很有吸引力，但他们总是对英国政策感到深深的失望。他们总是搞不懂为什么，你知道的，
Yeah, and we're both foxes. You know, it's also, but I think, you know, the justification for it, if I can put it that way, is this actually fundamental point that while politics was, the British politics was always attractive to Iranians, they always felt deeply disappointed by British policy. And they always didn't understand why, you know,
英国人没有达到他们自己标榜的标准。而且，我认为从我的角度来看，可悲的是，有一大批英国外交官都接受这一点。我的意思是，如果你看看他们的私人信件，他们会说，你知道的，我们在这里做的事情是让人们失望。你知道的，这些是我们的朋友，而我们在让他们失望。为此，这实际上是一个巨大的悲剧。我的意思是，人们希望未来……事情可以……事情可以改变。好吧，这是一个很好的结束语，阿里，非常感谢。祝最优秀的球队获胜。确实如此。谢谢大家的收听，再见。《The Rest Is History》。
the British didn't live up to the standards that they held themselves. And the sad thing is, I think, from my perspective, is that there's a host of British diplomats who all accept this. I mean, if you look at their private communications, they say, you know, what we're doing here is we're letting people down. You know, these are our friends, and we're letting them down. And for that, that's a great tragedy, actually. And I mean, one hopes that going forward uh things can be uh things can be changed well that's a fine note on which to end ali thanks so much um and may the best team win indeed thanks all for listening bye The Rest Is History.
如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。TheRestIsEntertainment.com 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. TheRestIsEntertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需收听加长节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩下的事》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。TheRestIsEntertainment.com 本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。